comment ça va tristane ça va ça va bien
tout va connaissez tous le monde de nom
de vue ouais plastique bonjour ces garde
temps jadis dans
l'avenir comme tous les rêves c'est
clair dont pierre sled le mari de sophie
davant voilà jean luc romero et donc
brigitte lahaie qui ont créé un nouveau
parti politique qui s'appelle
aujourd'hui autrement qui est imparti
pour la 6ème république pour la
l'euthanasie active patata nazis et tout
le monde mais selon la mairie
finalisation du président
non non je ne citerai pas de noms mais
tout le monde a compris bien comment ça
va ça va très bien bien vous avez 25 ans
est journaliste vous avez une réputation
de night clubbeuse voir de bons
beauchamp on dit et on vous a remarqué à
l'occasion de la sortie de votre premier
livre qui s'appelle erreurs avouées chez
anne carrière où vous demandiez à dépit
paul de vous confesser leur plus grave
erreur voilà alors donc votre nouveau
livre s'appelle j'ai oublié de la tuer
alors vous rencontrez dans ce bouquin
c'est un bouquin c'est émouvant mine de
rien vous racontez votre enfance
saccagée par l'effroyable indifférence
de votre de votre mère alors vous aviez
des remords d'avoir écrit ça et puis en
fait quand votre mère l'a lu
non elle m'a dit qu'il était juste m'a
dit que je n'avais absolument pas menti
qu'il était juste elle a trouvé une
chose à redire qui m'a peut-être un peu
blessé c'est que m'a dit quand même pour
une maison d'édition comme anne carrière
je trouve que laisser passer une
coquille c'est très gênant et alors là
j'ai regardé avec des grands yeux parce
que dans un livre c'était quand même
fait un bouquin en dix ans on n'a jamais
intéressé à moi et tout est dit oui
c'est vrai et elle dit il ya quand même
une coquille c'est quoi la coquille elle
n'a pas retrouvé à part une question de
concordance des temps quelque part mais
bon elle n'a pas retrouvé donc on n'est
pas bien sûr alors vous racontez votre
naissance je vous dit roy keane au sens
d'un prévu pour dix minutes de plaisir
et pour le plaisir on n'est même pas
certain ouais bah oui alors vous dites
votre père beaucoup d'autres auraient
attendu la sortie de maternité de ma
mère pour la quitter pas pour quitter sa
maîtresse lui non non huilée il est
parti me reconnaître et il a perdu le
chemin du retour ouais faut dire que
c'est entre la mairie et l'hôpital
américain une distance effroyable on
n'imagine pas forcément vite un
serial-killer mon père non disons que je
pense que c'est s'est il fait des
enfants comme d'autres font des bêtises
je croise je pense pas que j'étais la
seule ils étaient mariés ils avaient des
enfants des petits enfants je pense
qu'il devait en avoir un peu une dans
chaque port comme ça et tu es bon voila
il m'a fait il m'a reconnu c'est dur on
se demande un peu pourquoi
donc donc c'est monsieur bah non c'est
monsieur bah non donc oui baptise son
petit fils le jour de votre naissance
quoi il s'en fout
si c'était pas le jour c'était juste
avant ou juste après mais apparemment ça
m'intéressait beaucoup plus en tout cas
que la naissance de sa fille ça c'est
sûr et votre mère aime pas tellement les
enfants elle trouve que ça fait du bruit
ça fait du bruit ça pose des questions
ça dérange ça
sa demande de l'attention s'appelait ce
n'est pas faux c'est un petit peu vrai
mais bon on n'en fait pas la wii balade
histoire alors vous passez votre enfance
attend de votre mère elle n'est jamais
là oui c'est vrai ça ça m'a beaucoup
marqué toute mon enfance moi je suis
pour moi l'image de ma mère c'était
quelqu'un de toujours en retard et un
jour elle m'a dit mais je ne suis jamais
en retard alors je lui dis bah si tu es
toujours en retard me dit non quand
c'est important je suis toujours à
l'heure donc dans ma tête ça fait
effectivement un électrochoc je me suis
dit dans tout est important sauf moi du
tout évident parce que moi j'ai jamais
vu à l'heure
évidemment pas là votre mère que vous
croyez que cd c'est à dire sur son sac à
main il y avait cédé christian dior vous
croyez que ça veut dire constamment
dehors
c'est
oui j'ai découvert beaucoup plus tard
que ça voulait dire très cher mais pas
du tout constamment 2 mais en
l'occurrence c'est vrai que c'était un
petit peu cela s'est elle portait
beaucoup de marquer beaucoup de choses
comme ça et notamment ce sac qu'elle
avait toujours un alors vous êtes livré
à la bonne marocaine qui s'appelle amira
et votre mère s'occupe même pas de vous
parce qu'en général les enfants quand
même les gens les prennent dans les
vacances mais vous ne vous envoie en
vacances avec la bonne marocaine au
maroc elle m'envoie en vacances elle m'a
alors faut lui rendre quand même ça elle
m'a emmené quelques fois avec elle avec
la bonne amie enfin pas de gens pour
surtout m'occuper dans un coin
mais effectivement le mans voyez souvent
avec elle au maroc en se disant que vu
qu'elle s'occupait de moi toute l'année
elle s'occuperait très bien de moi
pendant les vacances à priori oui en
fait est tellement bien de vous vous
êtes victime d'attouchements de la part
d'un ami de la bonne oui c'est
en plus je me suis senti un massage mon
nom je me suis sentie responsable parce
qu'effectivement elle a dit à son ami et
lady fait lui un massage elles adorent
ça et c'est vrai que notre petit enfin
j'aime toujours ça d'ailleurs mais bon
j'ai adoré les massages et donc je me
suis dit c'est peut-être de ma faute
puisque c'est moi qui aiment les
massages et ça un petit peu des vies
donc je me suis sentie responsable et
j'ai rien osé dire non
j'ai découvert plus tard que tous les
enfants et mes mains alors cette bonne
amie ratu sa meilleure amie dans un
accident de voiture après elle se met à
picoler et quand elle picole elle vous
frappe
et buvez déjà beaucoup avant elle a eu
cet accident donc où elle a tué sa
meilleure amie et et après elle est
devenue violente ça c'est parce qu'elle
est devenue violente mais elle a
toujours beaucoup bu et là c'est vrai
qu'à ce moment là elle débarquait la
nuit dans ma chambre en me disant que
j'avais fait des bêtises que c'était pas
bien puis tout était prétexte
c'est je pense qu'elle des charges est
aussi beaucoup sur moi le fait qu' elle
ne pouvait pas avoir d'enfant et moi je
refusais de la considérer comme un mets
donc je m en fait ça alors évidemment on
voyait un tas d'hommes défiler chez
votre mère vous dit si tu ce qu'on
appelait une femme entretenue donc ça
vous a donné quand même une mauvaise
idée des mecs quoi c'est à dire que ça
vous a rendu méfiante j'étais plus
méfiante des femmes que des hommes 1
j'avais j'avais presque un peu pitié
d'eux quelque part parce que je voyais
ma mère jouer à ce jeu est très bien le
maîtriser et eux se laisser tout le
temps en bobines et là dedans et j'avais
envie de leur dire mais enfin bon vous
êtes jamais que le numéro 98 97 tail 99
et je trouvais ça assez pathétique
finalement m'est donc
voilà puis amiral à bonn s'en va votre
mère quittent paris elle va habitants en
bretagne et vous restez seul à paris on
suit pas tout raconter vous restez seul
à paris vous avez 14 ans complètement
livré à vous-même oui sans famille
sans contexte familial mais avant je
suis tombé sur une famille fantastique
qui je donnais des cours d'anglais à la
plus jeune et me donner à chambres de
bonne et samar constituer une sorte de
cellule familiale même si ce n'était pas
la mienne jusqu'au jour où il y en a qui
est victime d'un drame hélas vous êtes
pouvait pu habiter avec eux lui avait
pardonné à votre mère oui c'est fou ça
bah il ya plusieurs raisons d'abord il
faut mieux avoir une mère que pas de mer
du tout et je suis je suis proche de
personne dans la famille donc bon c'est
toujours mieux que rien et le jour où je
suis devenu adulte enfin adulte entre
guillemets
elle est devenue beaucoup plus
sympathique c'est les enfants qu'elle
n'aime pas mais après elle devient de
plus sympa si donc bon qu'est-ce qu'il
fallait que je fasse ou décider lui en
vouloir à vie pour ce qui s'était passé
avant mais ça a mis du temps quand même
j'ai mis du temps à lui pardonner on
sait on était en conflit parental
enlevée des frères et soeurs demi-frère
demi soeur et les autres ils ont été
près de la même façon ils ont été élevés
par leurs pairs
et oui plus ou moins disons que vu
qu'ils avaient leur père qui était très
présent pour l'instant c'est beaucoup
moins posé et c'était pas du tout la
même génération ils ont bientôt 40 ans
tous les deux aujourd'hui cette enfance
saccagée ça quelles conséquences sur
votre vie affective voilà ça on a
beaucoup
déjà que je n'arrivais pas à vous fixer
non non ça c'est pas au contraire je
pense que je vais prendre à contre-pied
assez radicale mais pour l'instant j'ai
pas trouvé la personne mais c'est là
aussi
voilà je me disais éventuellement mais
n'ont en revanche au niveau de mes
relations avec mes amis avec dans le
milieu professionnel ça a beaucoup joué
parce que je pense que j'ai toujours
voulu recréer une espèce de cellule
familiale qui m'a manqué et donc j'ai je
donne tout de suite beaucoup et ça fait
peut-être peur aux six mois mais c'est
vrai que les gens et ça fait peur les
filles qui donne tout de suite beaucoup
là il ya un proverbe qui dit suis moi
j'étais chez moi j'ai de suite ça va là
oui ça je vais très bien c'est pas mal
là vous avez vous êtes bien débrouillé
non voie facile de venir vendre un livre
comme ça à tout le monde d'en bas c'est
pas facile surtout de dévoiler à tout le
monde ce qu'il ya derrière et ça a été
très difficile de dire là ils vont
savoir et c'est ça c'est difficile donc
le vent derrière c'est encore plus
difficile et pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de inhabituel abonnez vous y
mettez un peu de bleu